good morning Henry it's Friday April 9th
2010 at this moment for me you are a
tiny tiny baby however I am assuming
that you will watch this video when you
are a little bit older let's just be
honest here your dad my brother not so
good at the science stuff and he is
concerned that you're going to be very
curious little boy and you're gonna ask
all kinds of questions that John just
won't be able to answer luckily for you
I am smart in the ways that your dad is
stupid so we wanted to preemptively
answer some of the questions that you
might have about the world in this video
you are going to be portrayed by me
wearing this hat what are rainbows well
Henry white light is actually not just
white it's a bunch of different colors
all mashed together and when light goes
through water droplets those different
colors break apart and the different
parts of white light are in fact the
colors that you see as a rainbow why is
the sky blue just like I said before the
sun's light is made up of lots of
different parts and those parts have
different properties and react
differently to different stuff so in
blue light hits oxygen and nitrogen it
bounces all around in the atmosphere and
that is why when you look up the sky
looks blue how does the internet work
well Henry your brother and I make
videos and we upload them onto a site
called YouTube and then people watch
them and sometimes we get emailed beyond
that I really have no idea where does
the Sun go at night we live on a big
ball called the earth it's a humongous
ball and because I am good at science
and not sports we're going to represent
this ball with obi-wan Kenobi's head it
spins the Sun is also a ball but let's
just throw down and say that Obi Wan's
lightsaber is the Sun the Sun is here
always staying in the same position
whereas obi-wan Kenobi's head is
spinning so if we're on obi-wan Kenobi's
face here then right now we are in the
sun's light but as he spins around now
we are not in the sun's light but the
Sun is still always there
how do clouds stay up in the sky clouds
are actually made up of really really
tiny droplets of water sometimes when a
drop of water gets big enough it falls
out of the sky and that is what rain is
but most the time the droplets of water
are so small that they just get blown
around by air currents staying up in the
sky like a feather like a really really
light feather
where do hamburgers come from well Henry
baby cows are kidnapped from their
mommies at a very young age and then
shipped off to confined animal feeding
operations and then after they get big
and fat we kill them and grind up their
body parts will eat them because it's
delicious where do babies come from um
well when a male member of his species
loves a female member of the same
species he deposits his unifier haploid
gamete on top of her much larger
stationary haploid gamete why don't
trees move um
I because I guess they don't have
anywhere to go why is my hair dark
because your mommy's genes were stronger
than your daddy's genes is my daddy
screaming to video cameras because he's
talking to me
oh why does fire hurt fire hurts because
it's made up mostly of energy and when
energy enters you it can be pleasant
like standing in the Sun shiny day but
if it's too much energy will actually
start to break down the bonds that make
up the chemicals that make up your hands
that's right your hands are made of
chemicals and when that happens your
body is like no make that stop and so it
tells you that there's something wrong
which is why we feel pain why is my
daddy's hair puffy ah because he's a
little bit stressed out right now but
I'm sure that it has nothing to do with
you what is a Horcrux young man where
did you hear that word how do playing
stay up airplanes wings are flat on the
bottom and curved on the top I win that
shape moves very fast through the air
what happens is the air across the top
has to travel faster than the air on the
bottom there is thus less air on the top
and more air in the bottom so there's a
high pressure on the bottom and a low
pressure on the top and actually pushes
the plane up into the air why do people
do bad things that's not really a
science question you should probably ask
you dad about that one because their
parents weren't as kind and loving as
yours are what does getting knocked up
mean ah it's the it's the opposite of
getting knocked down question time over
but that doesn't make question time over
Henry I hope you learned a lot and I
hope you become a little scientist like
me those genes have got to be in there
somewhere John I will see you on Monday